in today's video we will be explaining
all jaw titans in attack on titan we'll
start with marcel galliard but during
the course of this video we'll be
showing you some of the lesser-known jaw
titans and even some flying titans too
let's get started marcel galliard was an
aldian born in marley at some point in
his youth his parents sent him and his
brother porco into training to become
warriors and possibly inherit one of the
nine titan powers marcel excelled during
his training and eventually he stood
among the seven remaining warrior
candidates when the time came for the
warrior candidates to receive their
titans marcel began to worry for his
brother's life in order to keep porco
alive marcel managed to elevate reiner's
reputation in the eyes of their marlian
superiors while diminishing porko's
reputation through his intervention
porco was not chosen to inherit a titan
and instead reiner braun was given the
power of the armored titan at this time
marcel was chosen to inherit the power
of the jaw titan the six warriors
granted titan powers were soon sent to
war as a test of their abilities his
titan form was shown to be similar to
his brothers as both were shown to have
long hair a thick black beard at its
chin sunken eyes and a small agile body
much to marley's delight the power of
the titans proved to be a devastating
weapon even in the hands of young
children marley officially began the
parody island operation a mission to
send the warriors to parody island in
order to take the founding titan from
the king of the walls marcel was chosen
for this operation along with reiner
berthold hoover and annie leonhardt in
the year 845 the four warriors were sent
across the sea to the borderline of
parody island after traveling through
the night the warriors camp until
sunrise at this time marcel reveals to
reiner that he was not meant to inherit
the power of the titans and he
apologizes for putting his brother's
life over rhinos unfortunately before
the matter can be discussed further a
titan rises up out of the ground and
attacks reiner in a moment of sacrifice
marcel pushes reiner out of harm's way
and is caught instead the other warriors
flee as marcel is eaten alive the one
who ate marcel is ymir so she is the
next user on our list yamir spent about
60 years wandering outside walmaria as a
pure titan during this time she retained
little awareness or memory which she
described as having been an endless
nightmare it was in the year 8 45 that
ymir encountered warriors as they were
making their way towards wall maria to
infiltrate it after attacking the group
yamir ends up devouring marcel galliard
and inherits his jaw titan power ymir
then awakens in a barren field with
strange formations of light in the sky
before calling it freedom soon after
this event yamir regained her
consciousness and human form she then
traveled to the walls and somehow got
access into wall sheena she then spent
the next two years living within
sneaking about and spying on their
society surviving as a skilled thief it
was during this time that she overheard
a conversation between members of the
church of the walls and learned about
crystal lens an illegitimate child who
had been given a new name her interest
in krista led her to enlist in the
military at some point during her
training the trainees of the 104th
training corps completed a snowstorm
training exercise arriving at a base at
the foot of a mountain there yamir
reveals that she is aware of krista's
true past having heard officials from
the church of the walls discussing her
existence demir uses her jaw titan
powers to get wounded daz back to camp
she is one of the survey corps members
taken outside walchina by mike zacharias
who also disarmed her of equipment on
suspicion of being a potential
accomplice to any lienheart after they
take refuge inside utgard castle they
get attacked by titans capable of moving
at night as the battle progresses and
their commanders are killed ymir jumps
from the tower and transforms into a jaw
titan for the first time in show she
fights the titans strategically
utilizing her speed and agility to avoid
attacks and aim for titan's napes
however she is forced to hamper her
movement to avoid doing any more damage
to the tower as the tower collapses
yamir orders her comrades to grab her
titan so that she can save them the
tower completely collapses burying the
titans under the rubble the survey core
regroups a top wall rose and ymir is
brought up via a lift reiner and
berthold revealed themselves as the
armored and colossus titans and managed
to kidnap both aaron and yamir berthold
asks ymir if she remembers who she ate
when she regained her human form she
admits that she doesn't but apologizes
when she realizes that it was probably a
comrade of his as they begin to flee
through the forest yamir notices the
signal flares and realizes that krista
has come to rescue her she demands that
they kidnap krista now and when they
refuse she begins to attack bertolt
threatening to fight them to death if
necessary she successfully takes krista
and proceeds to swing from tree to tree
to escape when aaron's power as the
coordinate manifests ymir senses it and
reacts with surprise realizing that
aaron's power to control titans might
guarantee a true future for the walls
yamir looks back to see reiner and
bertolt are about to be overwhelmed she
apologizes to historia and returns to
help them with her assistance the three
make it back to walmaria after being
brought back to marley yamir willingly
allowed herself to be killed and eaten
by marcel's brother porco galliard
transferring the power of the jaw titan
to him obviously the next titan user on
the list is porco but stay with us
because very soon we will be explaining
some more mysterious jaw titans after he
consumes ymir and gains the power of the
titans porco inherits ymir's memories
and understands her history and motives
but he sees nothing from the memories of
his brother four years later he is
present at fort slava in the middle of
marlian mideast war he is commanded by
commander mcgath to wait and be ready to
strike after they destroy anti-titan
artillery as soon as gabby blew up the
artillery porco joins the fight and
destroys most of the enemy forces with
the help of car titan inside the
fortress she destroys several anti-titan
artillery platforms in order to protect
reiner back at marley galliard watches
over reiner as he recovers from his
injuries when reiner awakens he thanks
galliard for saving him in force lava
but galliard coldly tells him that he
only wanted to keep marley from losing
the armor titan during a survey corps
well-organized plan to attack marley a
strange soldier leads porco and peak
into an empty room and captures them
into a hole underground after being
saved by the panzer unit he sneaks up to
aaron's attack titan and leaps onto its
nape but when he tries to bite his nape
he gets cut off by levi he is shocked to
see that the soldiers attacking him are
trying to kill him without any fear he
gets saved by pique and her panzer unit
after seeing that the enemy have the
colossal titan power as well as levi
defeating zeke's beast titan he gets
full of rage and advances towards aaron
after getting both of his legs cut off
by mikasa aaron places crystal inside
his mouth and breaks it taking the
warhammer titan as part of the
retaliation against parody galliard and
pique are sent to infiltrate parodies
military the two infiltrate the military
headquarters where aaron jaeger is
staying once peak has brought aaron to
the roof of the building galliard
transforms into his jaw titan form and
ambushes aaron he helps reiner fight
aaron but they both get smashed by rock
pieces thrown by beast titan galliard
realizes that he is unable to heal all
his wounds and exits the jaw titan he
allows himself to be eaten by falco who
became pure titan and therefore
transfers the jaw titan power onto him
this is where things get interesting
since in my opinion falco has some of
the most fascinating titan designs in
the entire show after devouring porco as
pure titan falco's unconscious body is
retrieved from his titan by zhang
kerstein jean suggests to feed him to
one of the pure titans but connie is
adamant that his mother should be
allowed to devour falco an argument
breaks out which results in connie
kidnapping falco and fleeing with him
falco wakes up on route to ragako with
no memory of any of the events
immediately preceding his transformation
gabby and armin arrived to stop connie
from feeding falco to his mother the
four return to shiganshina where they
run into annie leonhardt while eating
after the reunion falco and the rest of
the group work with jean mikasa and
pique to escape the jaegerists in
shiganshina falco then stays back while
the warriors and survey corps infiltrate
the jaegers hold up at the parody docks
after seeing griner and annie being
overpowered by jageris he insists to
help them as that's something porco
would do he runs towards them and
triggers his first jaw titan
transformation as a jaw titan falco is 5
meters tall and is much more
proportionate and muscular similar to
some of the previous inheritors of the
jaw titan his titan now has two sets of
jaws with the outer one being the
hardened jaw and the inner one having a
human-like mouth and teeth one
interesting observation is that falco's
jaw titan has taken on many avian
characteristics with his outer jaw
forming a crude beak and his heart and
arms and legs resembling talents found
in birds of prey these traits appear to
be a byproduct of zeke yeager's spinal
fluid which transformed falco passing on
some of the beast titan's animal
characteristics this is proving further
when falco's titan form eventually
managed to sport wings a tail and a
fully feathered body falco and peak are
able to easily decimate the remaining
jaegerists but as soon as they're
defeated falco quickly begins losing
control of his titan he attacks peak and
survey corps members and they are forced
to cut him out of his titan nape after
escaping jageris and arriving in oriha
it is decided that falco and gabby stay
behind with azumabitos and annie after
leaving odiha falco reveals to annie
that he likely received the memory of a
previous beast titan who was capable of
flight and theorizes that he could do
the same due to the unique appearance of
his titan which is presumably because he
ingested zeke's spinal fluid using his
titan falco flies to fort salta with
gabby and annie the three arrived just
in time to save mikasa reiner jean
connie and levi from being devoured by
an army of titans after the group
manages to detonate aaron's nape and
aaron becomes a colossal titan he flies
mikasa and levi to aaron's titan where
the two work together to infiltrate
aaron's mouth and kill him and now
finally the time you've all been waiting
for let's see how some of the ancient
jaw titans look like in chapter 122 we
get to see the first ever nine titan
shifters the first ever jaw titan looks
similar to marcel's jaw titan because of
the long brown hair it had armored masks
covering its face and looked a lot
scarier and more terrifying than both
porco and marcel during the battle of
heaven and earth with the help of ymir
the founder aaron summons all past titan
shifters there we see so many previous
jaw titans but it's only for a short
period of time and we don't get to learn
anything about them for example when
jean and peak try to get to aaron's nape
and destroy it they fight a bunch of
different jaw titans of course we
weren't able to draw all of them but we
have chosen a few that we think are most
unique and interesting two of the jaw
titans that attack peak look absolutely
amazing one of them had a helmet shaped
armor on its head and strong claws as
it's able to slice card titan easily the
second jaw titan is my personal favorite
it's different from every other jaw
titan because it has gold claws and gold
armor on its head honestly this one
looks like a hybrid between jaw and
armor titan so i guess it's possible
that this user possessed both titan
powers simultaneously if you like this
video check out the video about all car
titans in attack on titan